yo guys what is up in this procedure
math.dg here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video and today we got
this new DLC we got this destructive
madness we got the hollow dome so today
as of recording this it is Tuesday
December 16th and the priest Borderlands
the pre-sequel hollow dome onslaught dlc
has been released along with the
ultimate vault hunter mode free of
charge and the extra 10 levels free of
charge so this video I'm gonna be going
I'm going to be telling you guys what I
think of the hollow dome um kind of just
it why it's good why it's bad if you
should get it and just kind of my
opinions on it so what if you buy it or
have the season pass you'll notice that
by now it should be up for everyone if
you go on to your fast travel list
there'll be a new location called the
halidome head over there walk down the
path a little bit and you'll see a robo
trap and or hollow trap i think it is
and he'll tell you oh come over here hop
into this arena and fight and throughout
this whole time you'll get commentary
from of gauge and accident which our
previous Borland's vault hunters asking
athena about her fight but they want
only the bluff notes of it which is the
short details so you get the hollow dome
where you fight a whole bunch of enemies
from the campaign's that you played and
some new ones they fall in love there
aren't any new unique guys but there are
new mob types so this the there will be
some spoilers i guess you want to call
them spoilers like if you want to
experience this yourself obviously do
not watch this video go experience appre
self but I it's not very story based
it's an arena where you fight waves of
people now every the first four missions
or rounds have a have waves up to five
you see this is round two it has four
waves
each round has different unique optional
guides such as saving the scientists
activating the hollow pads picking up
robot parts getting vault keys etc and
so you can do all that I think it gives
you more money or may you have more I
think more money each I can do that and
every time you complete one of the
rounds you go back up to the hollow trap
and he'll give you the mission for the
next round and you can get you can get
choice of two things the first round I
think it's concrete it's always the same
thing um so it's your rewards for this
will be always be gone one of one of the
new guns or one the new skins / like
class mods for grenade mod stuff like
that this so to get all the new stuff
you just have to beat the rounds of this
now into the actual game play of this
the first rounds I'm gonna tell you our
slope they are very very slow and I was
disappointed in how slow they are this
might be different with four people
since more people you have the more
enemies you face however the four people
it might still be slow with them I don't
know since I've only played this solo
and to know I have beaten this in the
sense of what you can beat it took me
about three hours so it's that's
debatable like it's three hours to solo
and the first two to three the third
round starts picking up the first two
rounds of slow through ground and still
kind of slowed by the fourth round
you're good like you can see I'm
fighting all these enemies right here
and you might notice that this this is
one of the new gun this is the t4s are
the Taser if you will and the cryo
pistol I'll be doing reviews on most of
the guns so be on the lookout for that
so as I said it starts off slow and the
entire time you're fighting generic ba
legion soldiers and lost and Eternals
some and some of those rates there are
rates what are they called the things
that float around of the oh the a day i
completely forgot i don't want to call
them sentinels
the main boss um the aliens we call them
the aliens I get pootie that's an alien
yeah aliens daily that's what I've gone
on them so whatever is the race that
guards the vault I have no idea what
they're called um the guardians are they
called guardians I feel like the call
Guardians let's go with guardians so uh
you fire but guardians and opa Ava's and
booties and lost legion soldiers and
Eternals and that's about it so like the
enemies that you see in Tycho ribs which
is kind of what this place is similar to
in terms of atmosphere that's what
you're gonna fight if you like that then
woohoo if you don't then I don't know
what to tell you since if you do not
like fighting those enemies that is
almost all of the enemies that are in
this I will note that there are some
uniques there you do fight flame knuckle
and you do fight a an interesting
version of felicity overpower velicity
oh and by the way when you get the fifth
round make sure you like see that
claptrap telling you to not go into the
light you should go in that light
definitely like see the lamb looking at
right now you should go into that go
into that all right all right just just
pro tip pro tip all right ok so back to
the gameplay and the hollow dome so
there are those enemies and then there's
an interesting Felicity and flame
knuckle and also I'm gonna say I thought
flamed knuckle three times today once in
the once in the 0 4 times actually once
in ultimate vault hunter mode and three
times in this and he in in these are
waves and he's dropped the Newcomb ah
was it twice so either the guide the
flame knuckle in this has a high drop
rate or just getting really lucky with
my Newcomb's today so i'm assuming
Felicity still drops her quasar she
didn't drop you can see there's the
power Felicity power suit felicity I'm
assuming she still drops turquoise
walkways are at a high rate she can drop
any quasar from me so I'm not completely
sure and so it looks like this is this
is not going to be how we're gonna get
the legendary farming I
it like I know that's been a problem in
this game and this is not where it's
coming from i'm ninety-five percent sure
you can reset your quests in ultimate
vault hunter mode so all the unformed
bosses that's we're going to do it
you're not going to get it in this DLC
so if you're looking to buy the dlc for
that reason do not this is not what
you're gonna get from it however as I
said I think I mentioned this at the end
of each round d go up to clap trap and
you get yeah did you get your choice of
two amicably weapons or skins or etc and
so I have been using some of the weapons
and they are pretty cool there's I got
the Taser I got the boxee I got the UH I
got the Plunkett I don't think actually
i think i got the crybaby and i never
used it maybe it maybe that's it but
yeah so and another point this is really
rambling video but i ramble um when you
get into the later rounds it gets you
you get super constricted on ammo so the
first rounds are slow and you can easily
solo the later rounds I it is still
pretty easy to solo but you just got to
conserve your ammunition and yeah
conserve ammunition because the later
rounds like it gets to it gets to some
pretty ammo using uh extensive since the
waves are very long and one thing I do
want to know you can see this is the be
a round there are I think six rounds
normally there's either five or six
rounds i want to say six and then
there's the be a round and once you get
to the be a round you can keep doing the
be a rad you can keep playing the round
never goes the quest item for the round
you'll turned it in and you just get it
again so if you'll be able to farm than
all the new stuff uh easily you're like
you will definitely be able to get all
the new guns and all the new stuff one
thing I don't know is if the big guys
like you see this Felicity if I get
different bosses every run I'm not sure
about that I would really like that and
but I have not played the be around more
than once because it takes so long uh on
solo I
not play more than ones to confirm that
so that's basically all of my thoughts
for this hallowed my eyes said if you
should buy enough let's see I got three
hours of it just grinding and uh I
haven't gone back and played at which I
probably will i probably will play it
more the dlc the hollow dome is that's
it for the ten-dollar dlc is it worth it
i'm making my mind up right now $10 this
uh I'd say you would if you found a good
ten dollar game on likes a steam just
like ten dollars or below you could have
more fun you can entertain yourself more
with that than just this DLC so i would
say i don't know what i would say this
is not going to be the dlc it's going to
get you back into Borderlands the
pre-sequel if you like the game you will
like this if you're disappointed in the
game you will you should still like this
but you it's not going to get you to be
like oh my gosh boorlands p is equal is
now the best game ever liked before was
bab and that was great so that's all my
thoughts for this video I've drawn
droned on a little bits and yes I hope
you guys have enjoyed the video make
sure you keep checking on my channel for
reviews and stuff of these guns and more
borderlands perceived content since i
will be doing a lot of that i am doing a
lot of that and i hope you guys if you
guys made it all the way to this end of
the video make sure you leave comment
below telling me what you liked about
this video or your thoughts about the
hollow dome since like if you get all
the way here you've invested some
serious time into this video so like
there's probably two of you like say
this video gets 200 views there will be
two to three of you that watch it to the
end here like well i'm talking right now
i'm only having conversation with you
you would like one other or two other
guys and gals that's it it's just us
it's just a small of conference so feel
special if you're really special because
this doesn't happen with anybody else is
just meeting you guys so we've enjoyed
this video and I'll see y'all next time
peace out